EMBASSY.
THAT IS A BIG DIPLOMATIC
SHIFT.
BRET?
>> Bret: BENJAMIN HALL IN
JERUSALEM.
BENJAMIN, THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RAISING
EYE BRAS TONIGHT WITH A MOVE
TO REVERSE COURSE ON A TOUGH
SET OF PENALTIES AGAINST A
MAJOR CHINESE BUSINESS.
SOME SEE IT AS A STEP TO
EASE TRADE TENSIONS.
OTHERS REGARD THE MOVE AS A
POTENTIAL THREAT TO U.S.
NATIONAL SECURITY.
LATE THIS AFTERNOON, WE
RECEIVED NEWS OF A DIFFERENT
SORT CONCERNING THE HEALTH
OF THE FIRST LADY.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS
LEADS US OFF TONIGHT WITH
THAT.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING.
FIRST THING WE CAN TELL YOU
IS THE FIRST LADY IS OKAY.
SHE WONDER WENT A
CATHETERIZATION EARLIER
TODAY TO TREAT A NONLIFE
THREATENING CONDITION IN ONE
OF HER KIDNEYS.
THE WHITE HOUSE KEPT IT
VERY, HUSH HUSH UNTIL SHE
WAS OUT OF THE OR.
IN A STATEMENT THE FIRST
LADY'S OFFICE SAID MELANIA
TRUMP UNDER WENT ELM BOWLISM
TO TREAT A BEE NINE KIDNEY
CONDITION.
THE PROCEDURE WAS SUCCESSFUL
AND THERE WERE NO
COMPLICATIONS.
MRS. TRUMP IS AT WALTER REED
NATIONAL MILITARY MEDICAL
CENTER AND WILL LIKELY
REMAIN THERE FOR THE
DURATION OF THE WEEK.
THE WHITE HOUSE WOULD NOT
SAY WHAT THE CONDITION IS,
BUT ELM BOWLIZATION IS
TYPICALLY USED TO TREAT
TUMORS IN THE KIDNEY.
A THIN CATHETER CUTS OFF
BLOOD FLOW TO THE TUMOR
TUMOR.
IF IS IT IS BENIGN THE TUMOR
SHRINKS AND DISAPPEARS.
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
THE PRESIDENT DID TOT
THE PRESIDENT DID TRAVEL
WITH THE FIRST LADY.
LATER THIS MORNING HE
TRAVELED UP TO VISIT HER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HEADED TO
IOWA SENSITIVE TRADE ISSUE
WITH IOWA.
U.S. SANCTIONS AGAINST U.S.
TELECOM GIANT ZT.
>> .
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING THIS
AFTERNOON ZTE THE LARGE
CHINESE PHONE COMPANY BRINGS
A BIG PERCENTAGE OF
INDIVIDUAL PARTS FROM U.S.
COMPANIES.
ALSO REFLECTIVE OF THE
LARGER TRADE DEAL WE ARE
NEGOTIATING WITH CHINA AND
MY PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH PRESIDENT XI.
IT WAS A RATHER STUNNING
TURN FOR A PRESIDENT WHO HAS
RAILED AGAINST CHINA
STEALING AMERICAN JOBS.
ZTE HAD BEEN PUNISHED FOR
VIOLATING U.S. SANCTIONS
AGAINST IRAN AND NORTH
KOREA.
THE HEADS OF SIX MAJOR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES WORRY
THAT ZTE DEVICES COULD BE
USED TO SPY ON AMERICANS.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
AMERICAN CITIZENS USE ZTE
SERVICES.
NONE OF YOU AGAIN ARE
RAISING YOUR HAND.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> CHINESE OFFICIALS COMING
TO D.C. LATER THIS WEEK FOR
TRADE TALKS AND PRESIDENT
JINPING'S HELP WITH NORTH
KOREA STALE CRUCIAL PART OF
THE DIPLOMATIC CALCULATION
PRESIDENT TRUMP FELT IT
NECESSARY TO DIAL BACK ON
ZTE.
>> OBVIOUSLY THIS IS PART OF
A VERY COMPLEX RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES
AND CHINA THAT INVOLVES
ECONOMIC ISSUES, NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUES AND THE
LIKE.
IT'S AN ISSUE OF HIGH
CONCERN FOR CHINA THAT'S
BEEN RAISE WITH THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND WITH OUR
ADMINISTRATION AT VARIOUS
LEVELS.
>> MOVE BROUGHT A SHARP
RESPONSE FROM THE SENATE
MINORITY LEADER.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO AMERICA
FIRST?
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LATEST
ABOUT FACE ON TRADE POLICY
WON'T MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN.
IT WILL MAKE CHINA GREAT
>> THE BACK PEDDLE ON ZTE
KEEPS A WAY CLEAR FOR
CHINA'S CONTINUED ASSISTANCE
ON NORTH KOREA.
CHINA ALSO PLEASED THAT THE
U.S. APPEARS POISED TO OFFER
NORTH KOREA SECURITY
ASSURANCES IF IT DISMANTLES
NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> WE HAVE TO PROVIDE
SECURITY ASSURANCES TO BE
SURE.
THIS HAS BEEN THE TRADEOFF
THAT'S BEEN PENDING FOR 25
YEARS.
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER PUT
AMERICA IN A POSITION WHERE
THE NORTH KOREAN LEADERSHIP
THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS TRULY
POSSIBLE THAT THE AMERICANS
WOULD ACTUALLY DO THIS.
WOULD LEAD TO THE PLACE
WHERE AMERICA WAS NO LONGER
HELD AT RISK BY THE NORTH
KOREAN REGIME.
THAT'S THE OBJECTIVE.
>> MEANWHILE SOURCES TELL
FOX NEWS LATE THIS AFTERNOON
THAT THE PRESIDENT REALLY
WANTED TO BE THERE WHEN THE
FIRST LADY TRAVELED UP TO
WALTER REED MILITARY MEDICAL
CENTER FOR HER PROCEDURE
THIS MORNING BUT IF HE HAD
ACCOMPANIED HER, HE WOULD
HAVE HAD TO BRING THE WHITE
HOUSE PRESS POOL WITH HIM.
THE PRESIDENT AND THE WHITE
HOUSE WANTED TO KEEP TONIGHT
DOWN LOW SO THAT'S, BRET,